[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today we got
Josephine in is that Vermont hey
Josephine welcome to the show hello how
are you we're doing great how can we
help so I have a question about avoiding
lifestyle drift as my income goes up
um I am very frugal because I would love
to be able to not work past the age of
uh
50 and I'm on track for that as long as
I sort of freeze my spending where it is
now
and I'm always sort of torn because I
also would like to live a little better
sometimes I like to can I can I jump in
Josephine can I jump in really quick
because I think for audience this will
be interesting are you a part of the uh
fire movement or at least uh On The
Fringe of the financial independent
retire early is that what I'm
hearing no I mean I know what you're
talking about but my concern I mean my
motivation is more that my dad died when
he was
54 and I'm I work really hard and I
would love it to be optional at least
you know maybe I'll work longer
but but it feels like you're at the
point now where you've got a touch of
that movement in you where you're
working so hard you just want to enjoy a
little bit of life and I just wonder if
there's not maybe loosen maybe loosen
the belt one or two notches sorry for
that man metaphor there but it's like
you're living so tight and you're
squeezed with your time because of the
money issue and the work issue and I
just wonder if you can still retire at a
young age uh but also enjoy life a
little bit I I I wonder what's going
what are you missing what what what
would you say to Rachel and I I wish I
could do this every once in a while what
what's being sacrificed
well I mean really nothing I guess like
I I live very comfortably um but I guess
I mean the thing that I sort
of there something go back and forth
about is a new car ah which I don't need
okay and I worry that I want it more
because of like comparing myself to
others than what we're just talking
about it yeah what are you driving now
so it's a
2020 Mazda
SUV like the
CX7 the five the five yeah it's a great
little car W great for you K know Ken
knows his Mazda I well I watch a lot of
sports so the sport if you watch it
football the car commercials are like
all the guys are laughing that's the
only reason I know that I'm not some Car
Guy funny um that's a nice car though so
yeah you don't you're right you don't
need anything else and you shouldn't be
jealous you got a nice car yeah and
think Joseph and so let me say this I I
do um for your dad and his in his story
how what what um what happened at 54
that made that caused him to to pass
away he had an accident at work okay oh
I'm so sorry yeah that's yeah that's um
that's tragic and traumatic and all of
that um when it's sudden like that so
what I would say is there's part of the
motivation possibly I don't want to put
words in your mouth part of the
motivation for you that wants to retire
at
50 is a little bit of this fear that may
not be a reality in your life and I'm
sitting here next to Ken and I think for
I think the stars have a line today
because Ken is one of the best talking
about the value that you bring Josephine
to the world that work is not something
to escape but it's something that you
can actually enjoy and find something
that you find meaning from now I agree
with you I wouldn't want to be paycheck
to paycheck feeling like I'm still
scraping by and that I'm still so
nervous that I'm not going to be be able
but at this point in your life you could
cuz how old are you I'm 32 okay so at
this point in your life Josephine I mean
you have a solid 20 25 years past that
50 point 52 55 that you can put away
some serious money um save but more for
the reasons that are not completely
fear-based because I think part of
what's paralyzing you maybe with your
lifestyle is this sphar of if I spend
then I'm not going to have enough to put
away and if I don't have enough to put
away if something happens to me you know
X Y and Z and I understand that you know
there's reality to everyone's stories
and everyone is on this Earth a limited
number of days and we don't know those
days but but for you I think there's
some freedom to give yourself to say
yeah I'm going to shoot for a goal but
the reason I'm shooting for the goal is
not out of fear but maybe out of
something else and I wonder if that
motivation is different if that feels
different and your expenses that if you
do get a bump and a raise and you're
still being wise and you're investing
15% and if you're income and you're out
of debt and you have some money safe for
an emergency fund and you're doing all
of this that it gives you permission to
to give some of that away and to save
some of it sure and suspend it and enjoy
it so I just I I I would kind of focus
in on on that I think Rachel's on it
Joseph I think Rachel's got a great
point I think this is a mindset switch
here's what I'm hearing okay I'm gonna
say this really fast you tell me if I'm
right or wrong and I don't mind being
wrong okay you're Frugal by Nature
you're very disciplined by nature and I
think what's going on is just dealing
with normal comparison stuff that I deal
with Rachel deals with we all deal with
it cuz somebody in your life has got a
really fancy something something
something and it's it's a whole lot
sexier than a Mazda CX5 and I think
what's going on is is you're going man I
kind of want that here's what I want you
to do when you start to feel that way do
you want what comes with that fancy car
that your friend can't actually afford
and they're dragging around $750 $1,100
car payment that's real I'm not making
that up and I think if you start to go
what I want that would I want to have to
spend more of my savings on that and you
start to go well what would I have to do
to have what they have and I think
you'll go ooh I don't want that I think
you're going be really happy with your
awesome life in Burlington Vermont
you're killing it Josephine keep going